>> Welcome, everyone.
Nice to see a full
room of people here
to celebrate Carmen
Benito's republication here
at the Library of Congress.
My name is Talia Guzman-Gonzalez
and I am a Reference Librarian
in the Hispanic Division
here in the Library,
and it's my pleasure
to welcome you all here
to this presentation of
Spain and the Atlantic Coast
of The United States: Four
Characters from the 16th Century
in Search of an Author.
On behalf of the Hispanic
Division, our Chief,
Dr. Suzanne Schadl, and
everyone in the Division,
I would like to welcome you.
I'm going to give the stage,
the podium, to Dr. Eyda Merediz,
who is the Head of the Spanish
and Portuguese Department
at the University of Maryland,
who's going to introduce
the speakers.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Good afternoon.
I have to thank very
warmly Talia Guzman-Gonzalez
because thanks to her we've
been able to set up this kind
of partnership with the Library
of Congress for, i think,
the third year in a row of
presenting the wonderful work
of our colleagues
in the Department
of Spanish and Portuguese.
So I'd like to thank
Georgette Dorn,
who is basically the outgoing
Chief of the Hispanic Division,
and I'd like to welcome
also Suzanne Schadl,
who's going to be our new Chief.
And I cannot say enough good
things about the Library
of Congress and the
Hispanic Division.
You guys make these kind
of events really worth it
for us to come out here.
And -- and it's a --
welcome to all of you.
Thank you for being here.
And it kind of helped that
it's kind of humid out there
and we can take refuge
over here.
But you'll see that this'll be
worth it, every minute of it,
because we have the presentation
of this wonderful book written
by my colleague,
Carmen Benito-Vessels,
Spain and the Atlantic Coast
of The U.S.: Four Characters
from the 16th Century
in Search of an Author.
If we had any doubts that
Spanish should be spoken
in Virginia, Washington, D.C.,
Maryland, all along the coast
from the Carolinas up, this
book has proven basically
that it's probably the
first European language
that was spoken on
the eastern coast
of the U.S. We have
two wonderful guests
that I'm going to introduce.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to introduce everyone here
and then they each will take
turns talking and we're going
to open the conversation
at the end
so we can ask general
questions and we can,
you know, establish a dialogue.
So Carmen Benito-Vessels
received her B.A. in [inaudible]
from the University
of Salamanca in 1977,
pursued post-graduate studies
at the University of Lisbon,
and English Philology at
the University of Salamanca,
and earned her Ph.D.
at the University
of California-Santa
Barbara in 1988.
I don't want to date
you, Carmen.
Benito-Vessels has worked at
the University of Maryland
since 1988, where she is Head
of the Department of Spanish
and Portuguese and also been the
Director of Graduate Studies.
She's currently full professor
in Spanish Philology, Medieval
and Early Modern Studies.
Her cutting-edge research
skillfully combines classical
and contemporary
studies while insightful
and original combinations
of the diverse interests have
captivated a wide academic
transatlantic audience.
Benito-Vessels has published
numerous articles and chapters
in collective monographs.
In fact, the journal
Mediaevalia from the UNAM
in Mexico has just chosen one of
her articles from 20 years ago
about the Gran Conquista
de Ultramar
to be reprinted next year
in a special edition celebrating
30 years of the journal.
And she's also the
author of four books.
The first one is Juan Manuel:
Escritura y Recreación de la
Historia from the University
of Wisconsin Press from 1994;
La Palabra en el Tiempo de las
Letras: Una Historia Heterodoxa
from the Fondo de
Cultura Económica, 2007;
Lenguaje y Valor en la
Literatura Medieval Española
from Juan de la Cuesta
Monographs from 2013;
and the one that we
are presenting today.
If you haven't had a chance to
look at the book, it's up there.
Take a look at it.
It's been published by
the ANLE and just came
out of the presses,
hot from the press.
She's also the collator of
two volumes, The Picaresque:
A Symposium on the Rogue's Tale
from 1994 and Women at Work
in Spain from the Middle
Ages to Early Modern Times.
She has lectured
widely and participated
in international seminars in the
United States, France, Portugal,
Spain, Germany, Argentina,
Ecuador, Mexico.
Benito-Vessels is
also Miembro Numerario
of the North American Academy
of the Spanish Language.
We are celebrating her today
and don't forget to
congratulate her.
This is a wonderful
occasion for us
at the University of Maryland.
This is the kind of talent
that we have on our faculty
and we are very proud of it.
I'm also very pleased to have --
to welcome two guests that
we have invited for today.
Raquel -- Professor
Raquel Chang-Rodriguez
and Professor Allison Bigelow,
who will be presenting
the book for us.
And let me just give
you a brief introduction
about each one of them.
Raquel Chang-Rodriguez
[inaudible] is a dear friend,
wonderful colonialist.
Her Ph.D. is from
New York University
and she's Distinguished
Professor
of Spanish-American
Literature and Cultures
at the Graduate Center at
The City College (CUNY),
where she co-directs
the catedra [inaudible].
Her most recent publications
is a translation edition
of the Franciscan Luis Jerónimo
de Oré's Account of the Martyrs
in the Provinces of La
Florida that just came
out of the University
of New Mexico Press.
Other titles by Chang-Rodriguez
are Cartografía garcilasista
from 2013, Aquí, ninfas del
sur, venid ligeras from 2008,
Beyond Books and Borders:
Garcilaso de la Vega
and La Florida del
Inca from 2006.
And if you haven't seen
an original edition
of La Florida del
Inca, it's right here.
You can actually [inaudible]
these wonderful books.
And she's published
that simultaneously
in English and Spanish.
She is the founding editor
of the prizewinning journal
Colonial Latin American Review,
for we all are very
thankful, and the recipient
of several grants and awards,
including the National Endowment
for the Humanities Fellowship
and the Enrique Anderson
Imbert Prize given
by the Academia Norteamericana
de la Lengua Española.
The National Atlantic
University, Athens, Greece,
awarded Chang-Rodriguez a
Doctorate Honoris Causa.
She is Profesora Honoraria
of the Universidad Nacional
Mayor de San Marcos in Lima,
Peru, and [inaudible]
Academia Peruana de la Lengua
and the Academia
Norteamericana de la Lengua,
affiliates of the Royal
Academy of the Spanish Language.
Welcome, Raquel.
Thank you for being here.
I'm also going to
introduce Allison Bigelow,
who is an Assistant Professor
of Colonial Latin America
in the Department of Spanish,
Italian, and Portuguese
at the University of Virginia.
Her research on indigenous
literacies, gender systems,
and colonial science, especially
vernacular sciences like mining
and agriculture, has been
published or is forthcoming
from journals like Anuario
de Estudios Bolivianos,
Early American Studies,
Early American Literature,
Ethnohistory, the Journal
of Extractive Industries
and Society, and the PMLA.
With fellowships from
the Huntington Library
and American Council
of Learned Societies,
in 2017-2018 she completed
her book manuscript,
Cultural Touchstones: Mining,
Refining, and the Languages
of Empire in the Early
Americas, which is due
in the editor's inbox at
the Alejandro Institute
of Early American History
and Culture by December 12.
So cross your fingers for her.
She is a star coming.
So thank you again
for being here.
I'm just going to basically
call Raquel to the podium
and we can start this wonderful
academic intellectual journey.
[ Inaudible background speaker ]
>> Good afternoon, everybody.
I'm very pleased to be here
at the Library of Congress,
particularly at this
event sponsored
by the Hispanic Division.
The Library, of course, holds
many books that are dear to us
that do research in
various genres and periods.
And also it holds the
voice of writers, authors,
some of them are gone,
and I was listening
by chance the other day to
the voice of a dear person
that I know, Jose Juan
Arrom, that was recorded here
at the Library of Congress.
And it was really
moving and it's real
because he has been gone
for a number of years
and he was a forerunner
of colonial studies
and the development of
the field in the U.S.
I'm here thanks to Benita.
Thank you for inviting
me to be here.
Thank you, Aida, a good friend
with whom I have traveled
in several areas, including
the Galapagos Islands
that we were reminiscing
this afternoon on.
Benita has brought us not only
to -- to Florida with her book,
but I think also
with the climate.
How did you manage that?
And I want to thank Aida
for the lovely introduction
and mentioning that
I am distinguished.
Sometimes I feel
extinguished more.
But I am -- it's
great to be here.
So I will then read my
thoughts on the book
and share them with you.
I have some slides that I will
try to present as we go on.
So in this -- in the España y
la costa atlántica de los EEUU:
Cuatro personajes del siglo
XVI en busca de autor,
Spain and the Atlantic Coast
of the U.S.: Four Characters
of the 16th Century in
Search of an Author.
Can you hear me?
Im a little bit nervous
with this microphone.
I'm not Oprah Winfrey-like,
but so anyhow,
Carmen Benito-Vessels
aims to recover
without reservations the
early history of the country
of Washington and Jefferson by
restoring a glaring omission,
the Spanish presence
in our land.
The title alludes partially
to a drama by Luigi Pirandello
that in turn refers to a
novel by Miguel de Unamuno.
As the names given
to people, to books,
to geographical spaces are
not assigned by chance,
it is important to explore
briefly the connections
of this title.
In his drama, Six Characters
in Search of an Author,
released in 1921, the Sicilian
Pirandello presents the
relationship of the playwright
with his cynic protagonist.
In his novel, Niebla,
the Spaniard Unamuno created
a narrative based on events
from the life of its
protagonist, Augusto Perez.
Both works, the play and the
novel, question the relationship
between authors and characters.
They offer also a philosophical
meditation on existent identity,
the link between
reality and imagination.
At the same time, the
books inform readers
as to how a dramatic
piece or a work
of fiction should be written.
Like Pirandello and Unamuno,
Benito-Vessels carefully
selects her protagonists
and situates them in
a different paradigm.
The paradigm is the
reconfiguration
of North American history
of the Atlantic southeast.
Through the analysis
of the deeds
of two native protagonists,
Francisco de Chicora
and Don Luis de Velasco,
also known as Paquiquino
or Paquiquineo, and
two Spaniards,
Lucas Vázquez de Ayllón and
Pedro Menéndez de Avilés,
the author guides us through a
time when the Spanish presence
in territories now part of the
United States was paramount.
By charting the itinerary
of these characters,
Benito-Vessels attempts
to explain why they
and also others are absent
from the early history
of the United States.
It is worth remembering
who these forgotten
historical actors are.
Francisco de Chicora, or
Chicorano, was one of 70 natives
of the coast of the
current state
of South Carolina deceived,
imprisoned, and enslaved in 1521
by two Spanish conquistadors.
When they arrived in Santo
Domingo of Hispaniola,
authorities there found that
these natives were not rebels
and therefore could
not sold as slaves.
The group was released and in
their turn they were ordered
to return to the mainland.
However, the return
trip was never made
and most died in Santo Domingo.
Among the survivors of the
group was Francisco de Chicora,
who was baptized,
learned Spanish,
and began to tell the
wonders and riches
of his native land perhaps with
a secret desire to return to it.
As expected, such descriptions
did not go unnoticed.
The learned and powerful judge
Lucas Vázquez de Ayllón soon
became protector of El
Chicorano and took him
to Spain to the court.
There he met none other than
the chronicler Peter Martyr
d'Anghiera, who penned
the descriptions
of the land Francisco de Chicora
was telling about and thus began
to build the legend that
resulted in the expedition
to the [inaudible]
Nueva Andalucia.
Charles V granted lawyer
Vázquez de Ayllón the right
to explore and colonize
the lands of Chicora
and there he went with six ships
and more than 600 persons, and,
of course, the guide was
Franciso el Chicorano.
After arriving, Francisco
disappeared
and he was never seen.
The expedition was
a total failure.
Vázquez de Ayllón died
in North American lands.
There was a settlement
of a very brief duration.
The colony was called
San Miguel de Gualdape
and it's now located
in South Carolina.
The San Miguel de Gualdape
precedes San Augustin de la
Florida, the English
colonies of Roanoke
and Jamestown for
several decades.
In a map by Diego
Ribero, the area explored
by the unfortunate oridor
is called Tierra de Ayllón,
and this is the map
that Carmen has used
for the cover of the book.
Let's go to the second
character, Luis de Velasco,
or Paquiquineo, which is
another protagonist discussed
by Benito-Vessels.
He was an Indian from the modern
state of Virginia, Allison,
probably of Algonquian
ethnicity, who by force
or by his own free
will, we don't know,
joined a Spanish
expedition [inaudible].
Educated by Dominicans
and Jesuits,
protected by the Viceroy
of New Spain, and baptized
with his name, the young man
traveled to Spain, Mexico,
and Havana with friars who
insisted on creating a mission
in the Bay of Santa
Maria de Ajacán,
right here, Chesapeake Bay.
Don Luis managed to return
to his land acompanied
by Jesuit priests and brothers.
He served as a guide
for them and then later
on he murdered the
priest and brothers.
Pedro Menéndez de Avilés, then
governor of Cuba and adelantado
of La Florida, was in
charge of punishing Don Luis
and his followers
for their misdeeds,
but they were never found.
It is worth mentioning or noting
that Menéndez de Avilés,
supported by relatives
from Asturias and friends
from that same area, had far
more ambitions for La Florida.
No. 1, he was determined to
expel the French, which he did.
No. 2, he wanted to find a
land route from Zacatecas
in Nueva Espana in order
to cross the continent
and with the silver
from that mining town
and avoid the pirates,
French and English,
that were roaming the Caribbean.
No. 3, and this was
still interesting to us,
he aimed to explore
the north of Florida.
I'm not talking about
Florida peninsula.
Florida was a vast
land extending
into what is today Kansas.
And he hoped remotely
to find a way to China.
No. 4, to continue evangelizing
the native of La Florida
with Franciscan missionaries and
obviously to colonize the area
and establish settlement
as point of entry
to the center of North America.
He, like happens, died
of typhus before any
of these plans could
be realized.
In an account backed
by careful research,
the characters Benito-Vessels --
of Benito-Vessels acquire a life
of their own in a historical
flow where the predominant role
of Spain has been
historically minimized.
First, she explains, this was
due to the territorial ambitions
of England and France,
and later,
in the Independence period
and in the 19th Century,
to those who put
together a history tainted
with religious preferences,
ethnic prejudice,
outright carelessness or
simple ignorance of the sources
that amply support the role
and the presence of Spain.
Not many listen to
Thomas Jefferson,
and I brought his image to us
because he donated his books
to this very library, no.
Not very many listen
to Jefferson.
He was a reader of Cervantes.
And not only Don
Quixote, but other nobles
and tracks by Cervantes.
And he find -- Jefferson
frequently indicated
that in order to know the early
history of the United States,
and to establish strong
relations to our neighbors
to the south, it is
essential to learn Spanish.
Carefully chosen and
studied with determination
by Benito-Vessels, her
characters, de Chicorano,
Don Luis Vázquez de
Ayllón, Menéndez de Avilés,
can be added to other early
authors and protagonists:
Álvar Núñez Cabeza de
Vaca, Hernando de Soto,
Inca Garcilaso, Alonso
Gregorio de Escobedo,
Luis Jerónimo de Oré.
That, in the words
of Benito-Vessels,
constitute the missing
link to Spain
in the early modern history
of the United States.
Their career, as the
author has pointed out,
and I quote her now, is
full of the small triumphs,
great failures, and
enormous risks, end of quote.
Without exception,
Benito-Vessels' book illuminates
these complex periods
and helps us appreciate
the many facets
of an early Hispanic
presence in territories
which later will become
part of the United States.
The research summarized in
the book by Carmen also leads
to other facets of the
early Colonial period
of North American, particularly
to translation and cartography.
It is worth remembering
how Spanish sources related
to the area were put to use and
also the preference on the part
of the English to
disseminate works
where a given chronicle harshly
criticized Spanish colonization.
One work comes to mind,
fray Bartolomé de las Casas'
Brevísima Historia de la
Destrucción de las Indias,
translated with a very graphic
title of Tears of the Indians.
As for misrepresentations,
perhaps the most notable
case is a translation
by Congressman Robert Greenhow
of the Chronological Essay
for the General History
of Florida
by Andrés González de Barcia.
Following Anne Brickhouse,
the author explains how Greenhow
disassociates the history
of Virginia from
the Spanish presence
in that territory thus
diminishing its link
to the indigenous past through
the demonization of Don Luis.
In this sense, Benito-Vessels'
book brings
to the floor the debate
about what did give rise
to possession, discovery
or colonization.
Obviously, England felt that
colonization was the answer
to that, but we can just
talk about this later.
Central to the [inaudible]
illustrated by the biography
of the four initial characters
is the language of cartography.
Maps, explains Carmen, do not
just point to a route by means
of the images illustrating their
edges, the selection of drawing,
of a style of arrangement,
of colors and lines.
They offer a language that
first we must know how
to decipher, how to understand.
As we know, the Spanish
navigational charts were
jealously guarded in the Casa
de Contratación in Seville.
Sailors sponsored by
Spain had the obligation
to indicate new discoveries and
routes in the royal register
and could not discuss them
under penalty of death.
However, due to the
defections of cartographers
and the pressures of
other European powers,
secrets were frequently
revealed.
Benito-Vessels offers
a classical example
and I will bring this
to your attention.
The German cartographer Martin
Waldseemüller inscribed the
name of the continent, America,
in his 1507 map prepared thanks
to the information provided
to him by Amerigo Vespucci,
at that time at the service
of the Spanish crown.
Chapter 7's Cartographers to
Power is a true treasure trove
as far as information while
also showcasing the practicing
of the time.
As the author points
out, these struggles,
cartographic struggles,
make us think
of Edmundo O'Gorman's classic
book The Invention of America.
Imagine not only by chroniclers
but also by cartographers
who responded to the
interest of a wealthy
and curious European readership
devoted themselves to describing
and plotting the
wonders of the New World.
We cannot fail to
mention common practices
in the Spanish colonial
expansion evident
in North America and
in South America.
For example, in the
conquest of the Inca Empire,
the Pizarristas, or the
followers of Francsico Pizarro,
sought with earnest the
grave of the Inca kings.
It wasn't because
they were devoted.
They wanted to basically,
as far as the priests go,
they wanted to find information
to accuse the Inca kings
of being idolaters.
And the soldiers of Pizarro
or Pizarro's [inaudible] knew
that the Inca kings,
the Inca lords,
were buried with large amounts
of gold and silver and treasure
and they wanted to go to
where they were buried just
to check on the booty.
On the Atlantic coast
of North America,
pearls often replaced
the coveted metals
and these are also sought
in temples and graves.
In his account of the
marches of Florida,
the Peruvian Franciscan Luis
Jerónimo de Oré proposes
to activate in La Florida
a method of evangelization
that was a disaster for
the Indian population
in what was then the
Viceroyalty of Peru.
Deredduciones, it didn't --
it was never implemented
in Florida.
Now, in her desire to
understand the kind of history
that produces distortions
and omissions,
Carmen Benito-Vessels, a
Medievalist by training,
goes to the prologue of
Garci Rodríguez de Montalvo
in his recasting of
the Amadis of Gual,
the classic chivalric novel.
In his prologue to this
book, the author speaks
of three types of history.
No. 1 was a true
factual narrative
about real deeds provided
by a reliable eyewitness.
No. 2 was what he calls historia
de la afición, hobby history,
or writing history
for the love of it
and offering a partial
representation.
And No. 3 would be historia
fingida, or false history,
which recasts facts within the
realm of the real maravilloso
and is equivalent to fiction.
As we know, the three models
are evident in the stories
and chronicles about the Spanish
in this and its frontera norte.
The frontera norte is what
is now the United States.
However, clarifies
Benito-Vessels,
in the configuration
of the early history
of the current United States,
hobby history predominates
with the consequent exclusion
of the Hispanic component.
So in her book, Carmen
outlines this forgotten history
and underscores the importance
of its recovery and study.
I conclude remembering,
going back to the beginning,
words attributed to Pirandello,
and I quote, we do not give life
to a character by chance.
The victim helps us
to understand why the author
selected her protagonist,
the four protagonists,
Francisco de Chircora,
Don Luis de Velasco,
Lucas Vázquez de Ayllón,
and Pedro Menéndez de Avilés,
and placed them in the context
of an exact textual journey.
Like Augusto Perez in Niebla by
Unamuno, the protagonist refused
to disappear, they
clamor for recognition,
and from the atalaya, the
watch-over of your journey,
Carmen, who is a wise sentinel,
recovers these historical
figures and gives them new life.
In this way, the
book that we present
and celebrate today
contributes to the necessary
and welcomed rescue of
the early Spanish history
of the United States
in its Atlantic side.
I thus congratulate Carmen for
her accomplishment and thank her
for plotting such a worthwhile
journey, and I learned so much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Raquel, for
this wonderful intervention,
for reminding us the treasures
that are here at the Library
of Congress for all of us
to use, for reminding us
about the ways of
Jefferson, who insisted
that we all must learn
Spanish, and the University
of Maryland is here to help
you if you haven't started yet.
We have a pretty
serious program.
Come to us.
And I would like to basically
call Allison Bigelow now to --
and by the way, I
have to apologize.
I mischaracterized
this presentation today
as a book presentation.
It's really a mini-symposium.
>> Thank you very much for
the invitation to share some
of my thoughts on
this fascinating book
and the questions that
it opens up for our field
with this group today.
I'd like to begin by recognizing
that we are on indigenous soil,
the ancestral home of
communities like the Piscataway,
who were only recognized by
the state of Maryland in 2012,
and by recognizing
the many intellectual
and creative contributions of
indigenous women and men present
and past to the kinds
of academic exchanges
that we're engaging in today.
In his capacious
and meticulously researched
comparison of British
and Spanish imperial strategies
and colonial practices,
historian John Huxtable Elliott
names what is perhaps the
deepest and most persistent
methodologically challenge
in the study of the
early Americas,
our lack of a time machine.
Without such a device, it's
hard to say how the paths
of the two largest
European empires
of the Atlantic world would
have forked their ways
and forced their powers upon
the American landscape had their
circumstances unfolded
differently.
What would Spanish colonization
have looked like in places
without large mines and
without indigenous communities
who had developed sophisticated
metallurgical technologies
to process those ores?
What might English colonization
have looked like in a place
like Potosí or Zacatecas?
Elliott, entertaining a
well-reasoned counterfactual
in his books -- in his book,
Empires of the Atlantic World:
Britain and Spain in
America, 1492-1830,
published by Yale
University approximately 2006,
argues that if large quantities
of silver had indeed been found
in Virginia, there's
little reason to doubt
that the development
of an extractive economy
would've created a high-spending
elite which would have more
than lived up to the dreams
of the gentlemen
settlers of Jamestown.
But instead, the presence
or absence of silver
and of large native populations
that could be domesticated
to European purposes
had other implications
for the imperial enterprises.
These implications were
both local and global.
Local because they affected the
day-to-day realities of women
and men who made their
homes in Virginia before
and after the forced and
unforced arrivals of Africans
and Europeans in the region,
and global because scholars
trace the origins of world trade
to this historical moment
in the 16th Century.
Because silver was worth
almost twice as much as gold
in East Asia, Iberian agents
extracted it in the Americas,
shipped it to China and
Japan, and traded silver,
which they liked but
not that much, for gold,
which commanded the
highest prices
in European bimetallic markets
at a profit of nearly 2:1.
Then they used that gold to
purchase people and goods
on their return through the
Indian Ocean world, West Africa,
and Europe before
departing to the Americas
to once more extract silver
and initiate a new cycle
of world trade, slavery, and
capitalist political economy.
So these two factors, silver
mines and indigenous population,
shaped their respective
crown's roles
in all aspects of
colonial planning.
Because the English crown
did not expect great profit
from its plantations,
it maintained a relatively
low profile
in the crucial opening stages
of development, according
to Elliott.
In contrast, the Spanish
crown intervened heavily
in colonial affairs
and documented its
decision making powers
in nearly every aspect of
life in the Americas, letters,
books that were printed
and not printed,
petitions from colonial
subjects, policies determined
at council, and maps that
were shared and guarded.
Scholars who study the Spanish
empire do not suffer from a lack
of primary sources, although
these sources are often silent
on the kinds of questions
that we ask today.
Hence, Elliott's question
about the possible paths
of colonization can really only
be answered with a time machine
that would allow us to place
British imperial agents
in what is today Latin America
and to place Spanish
imperial agents
in what is today
the United States.
So fortunately for
us, and with the use
of textual interpretation,
cartographic analysis,
and historiographic study,
rather than the time machine
that our colleagues in physics
have yet to build for us,
this is precisely what Professor
Carmen Benito-Vessels does
in her new study, España y la
Costa Atlántica de los EEUU:
Cuatro Personajes del Siglo
XVI en Busca de Autor,
published this year in New York
by La Academia Norteamericana
de la Lengua Española.
That is, Professor
Benito-Vessels locates
in a wealth of documentary
evidence and visual sources,
many of which are housed here
in the Library of Congress,
the materials for a history
of Spanish colonization
in what is today
Maryland, Virginia, Georgia,
and the Carolinas, and what was
at the time a complex
constellation
of Algonquian-speaking
communities who traded
with diverse indigenous peoples,
like copper-producing cultures
of present-day Michigan
and Iroquois merchants
from present-day New York.
These were not separate closed
communities but critical players
in a dynamic indigenous
world that negotiated change
and continuity before
and after colonization.
Two historical actors
from these communities,
two indigenous historical
actors from these communities,
are at the heart of
Benito-Vessels' book,
Francisco Chicora, or Chicorano
in Spanish-language sources,
a man we think to have
been Catawba based
on where he was captured
by licenciado Lucas Vázquez
de Ayllón, for whom he served
as a guide and interpreter in
what is now Georgia, Virginia,
and the Carolinas, and
Don Luis de Velasco,
named after the Viceroy of
New Spain, who served as guide
and interpreter for Pedro
Menéndez de Avilés
in what is now Florida
and South Carolina.
The book focuses on
these two indigenous men,
although there are many other
native actors whose histories we
could trace as message-saving
go-betweens.
The decision to reveal
and conceal information,
decisions made by men
like Juanillo [Inaudible]
in North America, by women
like Pocahontas in Tidewater,
Virginia, Doña Maria
Magdalena and Antonia
in Timucuan-speaking regions
of La Florida, Doña Marina
or La Malinche in Mexico,
and the unnamed informants whom
Colon took as his prisoners
on La Hispaniola on
November 12, 1492,
believing that the women
would teach him their language
and that native men
would not run away
if Iberian forces held their
families, shaped the movement
of Spanish imperial
agents as well as those
of the many Italian explorers
and Portuguese subjects
who Carmen quite rightly
points out worked on behalf
of the Spanish crown
in these early years
of New World contact
and conquest.
As these examples suggest,
La Florida was a space
of contested waters and
unstable ground, a shifting site
of imperial rivalry between
and among factors of English,
French, Spanish, and Portuguese
colonists who negotiated
with indigenous confederations,
or empires, as some might say,
given that Captain John
Smith calls paramount chief
Wahunsenacawh, known as Powhatan
in English-language
sources, an emperor.
And yet, as Benito-Vessels
shows in her book,
much of this multilingual
pluricultural past has been
papered over, or perhaps
more accurately whitewashed,
in a series of historical
distortions, intentional or not,
that have reinforced
the narrative
of what she beautifully calls
"la accidental
occidentalización de los
Estados Unidos" or the careful
fashioning of the history
of the United States
into a narrative
of white Western modernity.
Professor Benito-Vessels
makes a convincing
and well-documented case
for a determined crafting
of Western identity and heritage
in British-speaking
North America,
one that marginalized
its indigenous roots,
African histories, and
multiple European colonizations.
As we learn in España y la
Costa Atlántica de los EEUU,
the making of an anglophone
national identity was a slow
process that unfolded
over time as 19th
and 20th Century academics
and government officials
like William Gilmore
Simms, Robert Greenhow,
mentioned by Raquel, and
Frederick Jackson Turner funded,
wrote, published, cited,
and taught histories
in which England and France
became meta-geographic points
of reference.
Meta-geographic, Carmen
explains, in the sense
that these thinkers
use cartographic logic
and spatial imaginaries to
project a particular vision
about their country,
its origins,
and its place in the world.
They chose to adopt France
and England rather than Spain
or Portugal as critical points
of reference in this making
of national mythology.
France's alignment with
England, in contradiction
with other romance-speaking
languages,
where cause philosopher Immanuel
Kant's two-part taxonomy
of the character of the nations
articulated in his observations
on the feeling of the
beautiful and sublime.
Writing in 1798, Kant sketched
a model of world division
in which France, England,
and Germany stood on one side
and Spain, Italy, and
Portugal on the other.
These six European powers
form the analogical root
of his comparative
framework wherein he writes,
"If the Arabs are as it were
the Spaniards of the Orient,
then the Persians are
the Frenchmen of Asia
and the Japanese can be regarded
as it were as the Englishmen
of this part of the world."
Such 18th Century assessments
were not just anthropological
aesthetic or racist.
They were, for Kant, evaluations
of morality as he argued,
"The characters of mind of
the people are most evident
in that -- in them
which is moral."
Over time, these moral
geographic assessments became
indistinguishable from
ideas about languages
and the people who speak them.
According to Walter
Mignolo, in the transition
from Renaissance humanism to
18th Century Enlightenment,
English, German, and French
replace Spanish, Italian,
and Portugese as the perceived
knowledge-generating grammars
of reason and scientific
modernity.
In Mignolo's compelling history
of the perception and power
of language, there
was a fracture
within the romance languages
and the fault line was French.
Although French maintained what
he calls the expressive flair
attributed to romance languages,
it was also the language
of philosophical rigor and one
of the colonial power's
modernity.
After World War II, these
divisions were magnified
by new geographic
interpretations
of political economy in which
much of the Francophone world,
with the exception of Canada,
he notes, began to share
with Spanish its belonging
to the Third World.
As Mignolo argues
based on his reading
of Martinique philosopher Frantz
Fanon's Black Skin, White Masks,
to understand how these
processes developed in the 18th
and 19th Centuries and how they
came to exert such influence
over the 20th Century world, to
say nothing of our world today,
we must return to the kinds
of spatial projections,
geographic imaginaries, and
real world questions of power
that Carmen Benito-Vessels
locates
in the 16th Century
inter-imperial contest to name,
claim, and colonize particular
parts of the Americas.
At least 17 maps
produced between 1526
and 1570 plot Las Tierras de
Ayllón on the territories
that we now think of as
part of the ecosystem
of the Chesapeake Bay as
well as fictional projections
that linked Virginia
and Maryland
with Zacatecas and
the South Sea.
As late as 1650, English
promotional agents
like John Ferrar and
Edward Williams printed maps
in which the backside of
Virginia led to commerce
with Asia via the South Sea.
English imperial
projectors thought
that the Virginia colony would
become if not a land of milk
and honey, then certainly one
with a vibrant culture of wine
and a lucrative silk industry.
Because Virginia was found on
the same latitude as China,
Virginian silkworks would equal
or exceed what Williams called
the more opulent provinces
of the East to their
wealth, reputation,
and greatness (besides the most
Christian of all improvements,
the converting many
thousands of the natives).
These lines from
Williams' Virginia:
more especially the
south part thereof,
richly and truly valued,
published in London in 1650,
suggests how the same
[inaudible] logic
that gave pride of place to
latitude rather than longitude,
as we see with Ayllón,
influence later generations
of projectors.
Recall that we heard that
Chicora in Nueva Andalucia,
or lands fit for peopling,
porque hay muchas arboles
y plantas de la Espana,
according to the asiento that
Vázquez de Ayllón negotiated
with the crown in 1525, as
Carmen analyzes in her book.
Williams' work also shows
how these English projectors,
by which I mean early modern
writers who proposed elaborate
and often untested ideas to
reform government and commerce
in domestic markets and overseas
territories, called projectors
in English and arbitristas in
Spanish, shifted the center
of colonial possibility
from Spanish Florida
to English Virginia.
Williams' Virginia:
more especially the
south part thereof was,
as we see in Carmen's book,
those portions of the Carolinas
where Jesuit missionaries
and Spanish imperial agents
like Vázquez de Ayllón
brought with them slave traders,
women to bear children, and a
variety of artisan laborers,
including masons, tailors,
carpenters, and ironworkers,
to create the biological
and physical foundations
of a colony.
And yet, as far as we know,
there are no archeological
remains to give testimony
to this colonial project.
Instead, we have maps
that record the failures
of permanent European
settlement, such as that made
by Diego Ribera in 1529
which relays how many
of the early Spanish settlers
of present-day Georgia
and the Carolinas died
of hunger over the winter
because they lacked basic
mantenimientos or provisions.
These moments remain
understudied in colonial history
because their brief
presences tend
to leave scant long-term
evidence of the things
that we often analyze,
such as political, social,
and economic relations between
and among indigenous, African,
and European communities, or the
realities of life on the ground
for these diverse populations
as they changed over time.
We dismiss them as
failed colonies
and we turn our attention
to the imperial projects
with more visible
long-term consequences.
As Carmen's work shows,
this approach is misguided.
And as I conclude today,
I'd like to suggest how Carmen's
book opens up new questions
in three areas of
colonial study.
As I see it, España y la costa
atlántica de los EEUU invites
us to consider three major
questions of failure, race,
and collaboration from
a new perspective.
First, it suggests that we need
to critically revise
dominant notions of failure.
This definition, of course,
presupposes an imperial
viewpoint
in which a successful colony
is one that takes root
and leaves a lasting
imprint upon the colonized.
That alone is enough to give
us pause, but it also means
that we prioritize places
in context in which 16th
and 17th Century events have
lasting provable consequences
in the 18th, 19th,
and 20th Centuries.
By starting with these later
periods and mapping questions
of power, inequality,
and colonization back
onto early colonial documents,
we are doing history backwards.
I'm not arguing that
historical legacies
of colonization are unimportant,
rather that we prioritize
particular histories
because of their influences in
later-day eras, and in doing so,
we miss important opportunities
to analyze what Robert Blair St.
George called the possible pasts
of colonial life.
We also miss opportunities to
analyze what colonial subjects
and imperial agents
thought was possible
at a particular moment in time.
These possibilities tell us
about the history of the idea
of the New World and they
are in many ways as important
to understand as are the
histories of the New World.
After all, Vázquez de Ayllón
may not have left a trace upon
the landscape, but his
story and the story
of his story inspired
other European agents
who viewed the 17 maps of this
territory to try their hand
at New World colonization.
Recent work on imperial
failures,
one of the two framing devices
of a volume on European Empires
in the American South, edited by
Joseph P. Ward with an afterword
by Kathleen Duvall and published
by the University of Mississippi
in 2017, provides what Ward
calls evidence of the power
of the concept of empire
to hold the imagination
of all concerned despite
the many obvious challenges
that would-be imperialists
face when striving
to bring their ambition
to fruition.
Indeed, this type of analysis
suggests that the study
of failed colonial enterprises
can reveal critical insights
into the many souths, a wide
variety of forms and experiences
of slavery, and myriad in
changing empires, nations,
confederacies, and towns,
as Duvall writes in
the closing pages.
Second, as we think
about these many souths,
works like Carmen
Benito-Vessels' book invite us
to reconsider our study of
race casta and the marking
of human difference
in the early Americas.
We know that there are
major differences in the way
that Anglophone colonists
in North America
and Hispanophone colonists
and Lusophone colonists
in South America
categorize human beings,
whose humanity they
denied, by external factors
like skin color, spoken
language, clothing,
and hair texture as well
as less observable features
like religious professions,
craft labor, and family lineage.
We know also that ideas
of a one-drop rule
and the proliferation
and contraction
of casta categories shift
by region and over time.
So what would it look like to
study early English reports
on indigenous communities
of Algonquin, Susquehannas,
and Cherokees through the lands
of Native American contact
with Iberian empires?
Recent research by scholars like
Alejandro [Inaudible] begins
to ask these important questions
and to do so with methods
that center indigenous
historical actors.
But more work is needed.
For example, we know little of
how the Spanish colonization
of the mid-Atlantic might have
shaped indigenous communities'
ideas about race and how those
expectations may have influenced
their interactions with black
Africans from Estevanico
to the 20-odd women and men
who landed in Hampton Roads,
Virginia, in 1690 marking
the first permanent community
of enslaved Africans in
British North America.
Cassander L. Smith asks some of
these questions in her research,
and Cassie would be among the
first to tell us that we need
to know more about the
complex interaction
of indigenous African
and European populations,
insights with layered
colonial histories.
Third, and finally,
Carmen's study
of indigenous collaborators
like Don Luis
and Francisco Chicorano ask
that we reconsider the nature
of collaboration itself.
As my colleague Anna Brickhouse
shows in The Unsettlement
of America, and as Carmen
points out in her analysis
of Brickhouse's work,
indigenous agents were central
to the movement of European
empires, shaping, sharing,
and withholding information to
shape the path of colonization
and to protect the
people where they could.
New studies of indigenous
translators and messengers,
such as Cecil Carrion's work on
gestures in the French Atlantic,
offers to extend our analysis
of indigenous agencies
into performative and
non-lettered realms.
Doing so also asks that
we consider what it means
to inform and to collaborate.
We used to study hybridity and
[inaudible] as powerful acts
of transculturation and cultural
accommodation, but now we see,
as art historian Ananda
Cohen-Aponte argues,
the hybridity cannot happen
without the kind of violence
in which one side imposes
its will and way of being
in the world upon another.
In a similar way, as we
begin to center histories
of Spanish America, including
spaces like the mid-Atlantic
and present-day DeSoto
County in Mississippi,
and to center indigenous
actors within those histories,
we will need to more carefully
and more critically
analyze the nature
of colonial collaboration.
Professor Benito-Vessels is
right to detail the importance
of la collaboracion con
el indio Don Luis as part
of the Spanish strategy
against Colonial French interest
and to note how Don
Luis sabotaged Spanish
imperial efforts.
So what then does it mean for
indigenous actors to collaborate
with colonial officials?
How should we study acts
of colonial collaborations
within what Enrique
[Inaudible] identifies
as the overarching
framework of coercion
within which indigenous
women and men made decisions
about where and how to work?
So as we think about new
directions in the field
of colonial studies, whether on
failure, race, collaboration,
or any of the other rich
avenues of inquiry laid
out in España y la costa
atlántica de los EEUU,
we can all agree that Carmen
Benito-Vessels' book gives us an
exciting new way to approach
and to frame these questions
in a rich set of
multidisciplinary methodologies
with which to analyze them.
Congratulations, Carmen,
on a wonderful book.
I look forward to reading all of
the studies and future projects
that your work inspires.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Allison.
If you're not blown away
already by the possibilities
of this book, you know,
I know that your
curiosity is now spiked,
but I will actually urge you
to go get a volume of,
you know, get a copy.
I was trying to plug-in
Carmen's book.
Get your own copy.
Don't be satisfied.
I know this presentation's
absolutely marvelous
and they have placed this book
in a fantastic context in a,
you know, multi-imperial context
and also present a really,
you know, the erasures
that are there
that are beyond the
Hispanic population and those
of indigenous and so on,
but go get your own copy.
And now I am going to call
to the podium my
esteemed colleague,
Carmen Benito-Vessels,
who will talk a little bit
about her project as well,
and maybe respond a bit
to her two presenters.
I want to announce that she
is no longer a Medievalist,
no longer a closet colonialist.
She has just come out and
she's now a full colonialist.
>> Thank you.
Very nice.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you so very much for
the generous introduction
of the previous speakers
and I owe a special
thanks to Dr. Merediz.
She is the mastermind
behind this event
because she created the
series and gave us a forum
for all the professors
from the Spanish
and Portuguese Department at
the University of Maryland
to be able to discuss our works
here at the Library of Congress.
I don't need to explain
where we are.
It's really a humbling
experience for me
to be here today and I
don't - I hope that my work
in a way is a contribution
to the legacy started
by Thomas Jefferson, and I
can make my children proud
of their mommy working
day and night
and be a citizen
of both countries.
Also, I don't have enough words
to thank Dr. Chang-Rodriguez
for her generous support
from the very beginning.
I was a little bit hesitant,
I have to admit, because, yes,
I was coming from
the Middle Ages.
Not the Dark Middle Ages,
the bright Middle Ages,
and having her accolades
meant a lot to me.
I knew that I had a story
to tell, but I didn't know
that my story had a place
in the new modern times,
in the colonial times.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And of course, Professor
Bigelow, she is -
she has been the most
generous person I have met
in the last few decades.
She accepted to leave
aside her work.
We know about the
deadline that she has.
We know how important
it is to meet deadlines
and she put her book on one
side of the table in order
to read carefully mine and
discuss it with such eloquence.
I think I'm going to read it
myself after your presentation.
It was - it was a very wonderful
and insightful reading
from both of you.
Thank you so much.
And of course, I
cannot forget the help
of my former colleague
Talia Guzman,
who has done impeccable
work in order
to make this event
a possibility.
We are here thanks to her and
she has had [inaudible] in order
to finally put us all together.
And of course, the former
and present directors
of the Hispanic Division,
Dr. Mere - Merediz?
No. Dr. Georgette Dorn
and Dr. Suzanne Schadl.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Also, thank you to my family,
friends, distinguished guests,
my colleagues, of
course, my students.
Thanks to you I keep fighting
every day and I keep reading
to know any more
than you already do.
And thank you to all of
you for being here today.
As I say, it is a pleasure
and an honor to be able
to talk a little bit about
work that is very solitary,
and whenever I have an audience
I try to please the audience.
Let's see if I achieve
my goal today.
And since I cannot speak
with - in an impartial manner
about my work, I would -
I thought that I could tell you
a few [inaudible] how I became
an author of this book.
It all started with a class,
a class for a summer session,
and that is an intensive
summer session,
five days a week,
four hours daily.
You have to be really, really -
you have to have good material
in order to captivate
your students
and in order to keep
your sanity.
So I started by calling
this class Spanish Treasures
in the Washington, D.C., Area,
trying to bring the [inaudible].
I didn't have any idea
where I was going,
but trying to link what I saw
at the National Gallery of Art.
Of course, we have
enormous treasures there.
It's easy to connect Velázquez
and Duran, Murillo, Goya, Greco,
and all these painters with
traditional literary works.
[Inaudible] so I decided to
go a step farther and come
to the Library of Congress.
And this is where
I came face-to-face
with Lucas Vázquez de Ayllón,
who was in the entourage
of Pedro Menéndez de Avilés.
I knew a little bit about
Pedro Menéndez de Avilés.
I don't think I have
heard the name of Ayllón,
or at least I didn't
register it in my mind,
and I came also face-to-face
and became good friends
with the two Native American
Indians that they are waiting
in my book, Chicorano,
Francisco Chicorano,
and Don Luis de Velasco.
So I started digging and reading
and reading more and more
and in order to reassure
myself whenever I write
to a colonialist or a
professor of English history,
I try to put just a little
question to test the waters
and to see what do you - and
not much in the beginning,
and I kept talking and usually
the answer I received was,
"Really?
No kidding.
Where did you get that?
The Spanish were
here in Virginia?
No way. And I say,
well, you know.
I think that these characters
are looking for an author.
I volunteer.
I volunteer and I will
be the author for this
and see where we go together.
So we also know about the
imaginary line on the Treaty
of [Inaudible], 1949,
which is marvelous.
It's the wisest decision
to divided the war
in between two countries,
Spain and Portugal.
[Crosstalk] logical thing to do.
No. Okay, so we knew about
this line but as well
if the Spaniards were here,
there may be other lines
that we don't know about.
Sure enough, I found a book that
was called Spanish Borderlands,
written by Eugene Bolton.
Coincidence.
I live, we live, my husband
and I, lived in Bolton Walk
when we were in California.
I didn't have any idea
that Bolton will come
back to me in my life.
So the other imaginary lines
for the Spanish borderlands
were a little bit blurry and we,
as Professor Chang-Rodriguez
mentioned, La Florida,
the colonial La Florida,
the limits were much
more extraordinary
than anything that
we can imagine.
Some of them, like Escobedo,
we don't - let's not be shy
and we'll put an image
between Siesta Key
and the [Inaudible] Peninsula.
Why? That's in my book.
You can see the picture.
So why? Why am I
going to be shy?
You know, let's go
all the way there.
I'm not saying he was right
claiming that territory
in reality, but what is
extremely important to all
of us is to know that he
knew about these territories,
that he had seen maps or he
had seen documentation in order
to speak about these territories
and in order to claim them.
So everyone, you know, you can
claim whatever you want to.
That's okay, you know.
What's important is to realize
what sources he was using.
We also find -
so the borderlines were a
little bit blurry, as I said,
for the Spanish borderlands, but
then again that's nothing new.
Professor Bigelow spoke
about Virginia having a
direct connection to China.
I'll show you the slide
later on because it's true.
[Laughter] And you know,
we all know that
California was an island.
That is the way it was described
in Garci Rodríguez de
Montalvo's Amadís de Gaula.
It was not only an island,
but it had a queen,
La Reina Califia.
So yeah, so we do
- we do have maps
and we do have literary
works and historical works
that can help us to document
what we call cartografía en
brocha, brush cartography.
Thanks to that brush
cartography,
the letter of Amerigo
Vespucci, who was a professor,
as Chang-Rodriguez said, was
working for the Spanish crown.
He described it so well that
Martin Waldseemüller was able
to do that map adapting every
[inaudible] what Amerigo
Vespucci thought it was America.
So what - it sounds so very -
I thought it was very puzzling
and I go back to Dr. Bigelow's
comment on the Native Americans
and the question of language.
Language fascinates me.
I think that is one of the -
is probably the most
powerful tool that we have.
It's the only thing that
connects human beings
and makes human beings put
at the same level as that.
We can create with
words the same way
that God created the
world with words.
So don't this - don't
take offense by this.
[Inaudible] worth exploring.
And these Native American
Indians not only spoke Spanish,
probably the very first
speakers of Spanish in this land
and we don't study them.
To make things even worse,
they tell the stories,
an oral narrative.
An oral narrative, as we
know, doesn't have an author.
It has a million of
authors and only one -
and we end that knowing
one version.
This is exactly the same thing
that we have with oral epic,
with the Spanish -
all the Spanish epic,
all the oral history
of Northern Africa.
I wish a commercial and we'll
speak about this tomorrow
at the conference
of the [inaudible].
So I thought that this
was kind of an issue
that needed serious attention
and I found myself that I have
so much material and so
many avenues to explore
that I was a little bit
puzzled and that was one
of the hardest moments
for me to react.
How to put this together,
how to make it readable,
without making it just a series
of lists which I use often
in the book simply
because I, you know,
I have to document what I'm
saying so I just use all
of the bullets to say this,
this, this, this in order
to advance the narrative and
to let the reader choose.
If I want to see exactly every
year, every comma, every period
that she is mentioning, fine.
If you don't want to do that,
you can escape - escape that
and keep going with a narrative.
But anyway, I think that
this book is just the tip
of the iceberg, at least for me.
I have many, many, many - and
I do, I mention that at the end
of the book, many other options.
And one thing that I consider
one of the achievements of
or one of the things that I'm
most proud of is this book,
I believe, is very
difficult to catalog.
Many definitions.
Many definitions will fit,
but none of them
will be exclusively.
And I - this is also a
collaboration that children,
I mean, their books have
a life of their own.
They are like children.
You have a child, but then
the child do whatever it wants
to do, and he brings you
wherever he wants to bring you.
And the book, that's in a way
some - has a path of its own
and you have to let it go a
little, come back a little,
go a little, come back a little,
until you find common grounds
and you become friends
with your own book
or with your own children.
So that ability of making
it really work was a
real challenge.
And as I said, if - another
two things that I would
like to mention about the
book and 'Im very proud
of is I didn't put a conclusion.
It doesn't have a final
- a final sentence.
It's an open ending.
And it's not that I forgot.
No. I didn't forget.
I knew I had to put an end one
day to keep my sanity, too,
but anyway, I didn't forget.
I didn't want to put an end
because the story goes on.
The story goes on and we
have much more to research.
And I wanted to have the
last sentence as a sentence
to speak to the reader.
And it's a direct,
it's a conversation,
that way the reader and the
scholars, students, right there,
all of you, have to continue.
Well, I hope that
they continue one day.
I came - many items
can surprise us
in the story of these
characters.
And another one, to go back to
the Native American Indians,
is that we have with Chicorano
and with Don Luis de
Velasco the first two persons
who partially achieved their
goal of defeating colonialism.
So when we're talking about
national history, well,
are they not national enough?
Why do we have to
prove in which nation?
And by the way, we use gross,
very general and generic terms,
the Indian Nation [inaudible].
I don't even want to
enter that territory.
The Indian Nations.
I think that they can transfer a
scholarship in order to be able
to dominate this field a little
bit because they are a question
of nationality and defending
your own land, that feeling
that you are not national and
you belong to a different race
or you are still national.
Anyway, of course, there are
many other points in the book
that I will have lots to pursue
because they are really funny.
But I didn't do it
because I would lose track
and that's why I have many
pages so I don't lose track.
But there are - they're
the perfect explanation
of how histories are
always a mix of at least -
of at least three kind
of narratives: fingida,
afición y verdadera,
which is fictitious,
[inaudible], and true history.
All the histories have
that and the fictious
and this combination
of three, I think,
that is marvelously represented
in, for instance, the wife,
the Spanish wife of Pedro
Menéndez de Avilés,
Doña Maria de Solis.
Pedro Menéndez de
Avilés's family wanted that -
wanted to keep that
guy close to home.
Apparently, he was not
a very peaceful person.
And they tried to marry him
or to make an engagement
early in his teenage years.
He was not very successful.
Anyway, he ended up
marrying this Maria de Solis,
and this Doña Maria
de Solis was informed
by Pedro Menéndez de
Avilés that they were going
to cross the Atlantic
and they were going
to set up in La Florida.
So Doña Maria de Solis
puts to shame any character
from [Inaudible], Mama
Grande or anybody else,
and they're put to shame.
They don't get even
close to this Solis.
She decided, okay, it's
time to cross the Atlantic.
I want to bring my bed, my
bedspread, my furniture,
my silverware, enough plates
for 18 people, chairs,
enough products to cook
cocido, Spanish cocido,
nails to build my future house.
She was determined
to settle there.
And that's another point.
If she was going to settle,
that's another very
interesting difference
between when we're speaking
history of the English
or the French and the
Spanish or the Portuguese.
We are conquistadores,
they are settlers.
I think that this lady
was quite a settler.
I mean, she got everything
that one may need
in her future - in
her future home.
We have mentioned before that
Amerigo Vespucci's Letter
and how that letter - by
the way, there's a copy
in this library, in the
basement of this library,
and here in the basement of this
library you have the richest
collection of maps in the world.
Four million is the last
number that I - five?
Five, thank you.
I knew that my [inaudible].
Five million maps.
So you don't have
anything else to do,
get yourself a library card.
And there's five million there.
Five treasures that belong to
the early American history,
and one of them was shown
by Professor Chang-Rodriguez
by Diego Ribera in 1629.
And there are others like the
Romeo and other Portolanos.
Wonderful, wonderful,
wonderful, wonderful maps,
and they're all right here.
Anyway, I'm losing my track.
I was talking about Amerigo
Vespucci, how the importance
of secrecy in the Casa de
Contratación and the failure
to keep those secrets and
how they were sold, stolen,
or simply spoken about in a bar.
Who knows?
Anyway, I want to
conclude because I want
to present just some
images to prove
that what we were
telling you is true.
And just one - a
couple of things.
I also expect that when
my book is read, it is -
I point out I say that's
several times in the book,
but I hope you use erasers
in the reader's mind
because sometimes we only
read what we want to read
and not what is written.
And what is written in the book
is that I do not point my finger
to anybody or any
country, and I do -
the only thing I do
is point out facts,
and there's plenty
of them, believe me.
Also, I do not claim
any national territory.
I'm beyond that.
I claim the knowledge of
territoriality and the maps
that prove that territoriality.
Also, I hope that this
book is a thank you note
to the U.S. universities.
I would not have been able
to write - to write this book
or any of my books if I had
not been under the auspices
of American universities.
And finally is the late, late,
very late thank you note also
for my late parents who
bought me my first book,
the book that I own
and treasure.
I still have it in my library.
It was a book, a
history of Spain.
It was, well, it was
much better than that.
It was called Soy Español.
[ Laughter ]
What's there I forgot, but
what I didn't forget was the
beautiful form of that
book, the beautiful form
in which the stories were
told, they were all fantastic.
And I loved that.
I liked it so much
that in the cover
of the book I wrote my name
and four family names, not two,
four family names and my age
so I look like an author.
Finally, I have my own book
and only two last names.
But anyway, before we conclude
and have time for questions,
I would like to show you
just a couple of images.
This is - we know
very well this map.
This is the Juan de
la Cosa Map in 1500.
In it, we have the -
[ Background speaking ]
So this is a very famous map
and we all know about it.
It was - it was drawn
after [inaudible]
voyages in the Atlantic.
[Inaudible] was working first
in Spain and then in England,
and we will go through that
later, and this is the -
[ Inaudible ]
And we have the Amerigo
Vespucci with America,
the way it was described by
Amerigo Vespucci in his letter
to the King of Spain
and Portugal.
We have in the book you can find
an engraving showing this part
of the King - of Vespucci
leaving the letter.
This is the - the quality is the
best I could with what I have.
It is a very [inaudible].
I call him that way because
he was signing that name.
He was the nephew of Amerigo
Vespucci, or Amerigo Vespuccio,
and in this I think
that [inaudible]
where the Spanish line
is and the imperial flag
of Charles I is right there
in the middle of the country.
And of course -
[ Inaudible ]
You have an image from a
modernization of that map
and you see all the important
things, not only the names
of the regions but
also the [inaudible]
and towns are all in Spanish.
This is the [inaudible]
by Diego Ribero, 1527.
We'll see detail later on.
[Inaudible] 1527, 1529.
We have the discussion
on these two narratives.
They are almost identical.
And what is interesting
is the detail.
Here we have -
[ Inaudible ]
This is another very
interesting and unique map.
It's housed in this library.
[Inaudible] 1562, and
what is interesting is
that Valla de Santa Maria
is really not located
in the Roanoke Sound
area and - which is new
and more interesting is that
the English call it the Roanoke
Colony, in Roanoke, of course,
thinking that they were going
to Valla de Santa Maria.
This - Sir Walter
Raleigh was guided
by a Portuguese pilot
[inaudible].
This pilot was not interested
in how things [inaudible].
He was interested in
letting his own portion
and they were fighting all
the way and [inaudible] knew
about the information
provided by the [inaudible].
And that's my theory.
Some will refute it,
but I have the maps.
[Laughter] I'll be
happy - I'll be happy
to continue the conversation
because I'm not the
cartographer.
And to show you California
was an island.
It was an island
all the way to 1658.
[ Inaudible ]
In which we have the
information here in the corner
from the [Inaudible] and
the chronicles, I think,
described by Chicora
as paradise.
And to prove his idea was
convincing [inaudible].
These are numerous forts
and missions founded
by the Spaniards in Florida
all the way to Virginia
and [inaudible] related
to the New World, I think,
Atlantic City, and his
idea of personifying
and making [inaudible]
whatever you want to make.
And of course, España
is at the head.
England's at the bottom.
Okay, gracias.
[ Applause ]